aujourd'hui c'est notre dernier jour en
cinq ans la ville natale de ma mère a
donc en quelques heures
on va être sur un avion en route vers la
chan est ici à cinq ans il y avait
beaucoup de choses que j'ai aimé que
j'ai apprécié par exemple la boue
partout où on allait il y avait de la
bonne pauvres comme les pâtes et chaud
et les silos zaho qui sont les smoothies
aux fraises et les ennemis et les plus
forts ensuite hier en italie au make up
delta il y avait une femme qui paient
une barque sur un fleuve on était cinq
sur la barque mais elle était si forte
et elle continue à 17h d'avoir un grand
sourire et ça m'a vraiment marqué et
enfin aujourd'hui on a on a interviewé
une femme une jeune femme très
intelligente qui essaye de préserver un
art ancien vie de l'amiens elle était
définitivement très inspirante